that's good I'm here now the last
question okay
it looks very similar but people get
thrown by it just because the variable
where is the variable what are we trying
to solve for where is it that's exactly
right
the variable is the upper bound right so
what this is really asking is I'm sorry
what's the low back everyone okay so the
same as the one we just had
so they say I can't look start from
Paulo - you said definite integral right
definite integral of this so said stop
from pilots too much is here okay now
the question is with this X here how far
do I need to go integrating this thing
that's it right so that I get such in
such an area now what is the area I
remember well it's T isn't it that
doesn't matter cuz it's just a it's just
a dummy right minus log so the same look
this this is some this is some about it
what it is and they say half auto an age
ago to give this area on me kid to my
area is that big okay which is not the
normal way we do it we usually want to
work out what the area is and visa
define for us because the definite
integral but it's not that hard right
we've just done this so what am I gonna
buy on the left hand side okay so that's
my primitive so I want to evaluate it at
the two boundaries
yes okay so that's what I'm gonna value
eight your secular weapons of asked
question what happened on the right hand
side we'll get there in a second Richard
not nothing's happened on the right hand
side it's just a number all right this
keeps going okay let's do it
left hand side I'm sorry not left hand
side right hand side upper and lower
balance yeah so what do I got log of ten
now it becomes an X and you subtract
there hold on what happened to this
before
that became log of 1 which is 0 right
okay staying with it ok so now this
becomes 0 so log of this now I want to
get some kind of comparison right I'm
trying to solve for X so I want to get
rid of all these logs and tans
eventually yeah so the first thing I
want to get rid of I suppose is the wok
I've bought this so here but I've got
negative log over here so what impact is
that minus sign that's right it's the
same thing I did here right I accept I
did the reverse order right so I've got
a minus 1 here sort of put it up into
the index like so right so that's log of
1 over root 2 minus 1 okay
so now I've got one on both sides so I
can get rid of them and you know you
know in an exhausting stressed out exam
state you're like no idea what that is
except know what's the angle right
slightly sneaky but I was really because
I just didn't have enough marks to put
into one section right so so this is the
angle we just worked out right which is
yeah so now I multiply by two right yes
be happy can we go home so so raise your
hand if you're happy at this point
what was this worth this is worth um
this is worth two marks at the end here
so this this section damn you sooo much
who's happy is that is that okay so you
can clone up hands up strength come on
to meet people I see one hand survive is
that it two three four five I'm at five
so fast okay so hands down that means is
like you know fifteen of you who are not
happy why not
what's wrong with the answer but what's
wrong it's pretty good to me I think I
can give it a go I can get punches to be
planful I can evaluate it and I'll pick
money to fight for it looks okay to me
why would you solutions general
solutions on to something why or where
aa what general solution come into play
in this in Part D what step where
wherever I've used out something quite
significant okay and I said solve furet
that's all the question says what would
your answer be let's just assume radiant
I think that's the right answer
it is nothing given on this there's no
domain restriction on that you have to
say look there's heaps of angles that
would satisfy that equation so if
there's no domain you have to give a
general solution right but a general
solution is wrong because each X Y is
general solution wrong so just in case
you didn't if you're not following
where's this line here it's this like
right in the point of in the process of
trying to get my answer I've got 10
something equals that I should from here
by all right say there's a whole
buttload of angles that will satisfy
that equation why am i okay so we
treated triangle life I don't know which
other Padawans oh yeah to work out to
work out this value that was fine okay
but in question six there are no
triangles everything you need to draw
the board okay so hold on let's just
regather okay we're saying at this point
right at this point there are multiple
solutions tears right but I'm I'm
disregarding all of them and I'm just
going with this one the question is why
why would we usually say there are lots
of solutions but I only want this one
there are lots of solutions but I'm
going to disregard all of them what do
we what circumstances usually
if there is a restriction on domain like
it's a length its time it's gonna be
positive or whatever now being positive
doesn't help us feel right because you
know I can keep going right but there's
something else that causes a problem
right it's been staring you in the face
for the last 10 minutes ever I said this
is not a triangle questions right so the
triangle good would give you some
restrictions okay it's not a triangle
question what kind of question is is
when it's not I said this is a funny
question right because the X is in
another spot right so what is this lion
saying it's saying integrate this find
the area under that curve how far must I
go to get this area this is this is an
area question where's the area start it
start sometime soon which is here it
says it's well I can't I cannot get
backwards unfortunately the reason why
is because if you get your calculator
out that's positive I know it looks like
it's negative because of - it's actually
probably the canary why because Richie
minus one is point four which is less
than that's right okay so so this this
is positive so integrating backwards
doesn't help but if I enjoy right
forwards you know you can imagine the
area under the curve sort of filling in
right you're like where do I start
well wherever it wherever it is that it
stops we're suggesting three plan
more what happens what happened this is
minuses because this is an asymptote
right um
this area under here it can't keep going
it breaks right you can't evaluate pasta
okay the the integral breaks down
because what it really refers to is an
area I've caught you say facts the
breaking down a mass doesn't deal very
well with this infinite distance in here
right it's a definitely not surely think
about it oh yeah you know for instance
this thing is it's a famous series it
looks like it's gonna approach something
but it doesn't sir this is tied of
threads back together okay at this point
here I can't just go to that answer okay
I'm excluding a whole bunch of answers
and different number of answers in fact
how can I exclude it what exclude what
what sort of domain restriction is there
X X has to be you know in a very
specific domain right we already said we
can't go backwards because then you're
going to get a negative area it won't
work with this number okay but I have to
start upon two that's taking me forwards
and I can't get any further than pi so
here I say this is my domain and that's
how I can close off on just a single
answer this is the only one in the
domain okay because when you try these
these guys they're all outside